well continuing with the St Patrick's
Day festivities here's something that
you can try to make at home Chef Jeff
from Smith's Food and Drug the sponsors
of this segment are serving up some
shepherd's pie
hello everybody I'm Chef Jeff from
Smith's happy St Patrick's Day uh it's a
holiday that's close to my heart I have
a lot of family from Ireland and so this
is this recipe it also reminds me of my
mother quite a bit because she made it
all the time but instead of the corned
beef and cabbage we're making shepherd's
pie now if you're not familiar with what
shepherd's pie is it's like a meat with
potatoes and cheese on top of it I'm
super good now remember the shepherd's
pie we're we're hurting sheep or lamb
not cows so we're using ground lamb as
my meat base right here I have some
hamburger and or not hamburger sorry I'm
in that big deal it's Lamb with some uh
onion and what I'm going to do now I've
cooked that down and took all the extra
fat out of it I'm gonna add some things
to it I've got some beef broth I have
some Worchester Shire sauce garlic a
little bit of flour to thicken it and
then I have rosemary thyme parsley salt
and pepper and then some tomato paste
I'm gonna go ahead and stir that
together and just kind of let it do its
thing and then we'll go on to the potato
portion of this takes just a second
okay meat's going now it's now potato
time I've just uh boiled some potatoes
got all the extra moisture out I always
put them back in the hot pan just to get
rid of that extra moisture to that I'm
gonna add salt pepper and garlic powder
and then I'm gonna add some Parmesan
cheese and then cream and butter that
are warm I don't want to put cold cream
and butter into mashed potatoes because
then they'll get gummy so I'm just going
to mash those until they're creamy
okay my potatoes are all ready to go
nice and creamy and cheesy now I'm going
to add some peas carrots and corn to my
meat mixture and then I'm gonna get this
ready to go in the oven my oven is
preheating to 400 Degrees get a nice
baking dish of some kind
just kind of spread all that yumminess
in the bottom of the pan
and then I do have to say though that
when my mom made this she always used a
ground beef now if you use ground beef
it's not called shepherd's pie it's
called cottage pie but because ground
lamb wasn't as popular a thing but we'll
get the potatoes on there spread them
get them cheesed up and then it will go
in the oven takes just a second to
spread that out
potatoes are spread but I have to put
more cheese on it because it's delicious
and so I put Irish cheddar on there just
for the season right and so Irish
cheddar goes on top you can find that at
Murray's Cheese at your local Smiths and
then into the oven it goes for about 25
minutes just until that cheese melting
is nice and bubbly on top okay so it's
out of the oven it took it about 25
minutes or so it's time to serve it up
what I love about this meal is that it
reminds me of my mom also it's got
everything in one it's got yours it's
got your meat it's got your veggies it's
got your starch it's got it all in one
and it's a great way to celebrate St
Patrick's Day
speaking of which happy St Patrick's Day
you can find all of these ingredients at
your local Smiths thank you so much for
watching thank you for shopping we'll
see you next time bye everyone
for this recipe and for more information
visit smithsfoodanddrug.com there's more
Las Vegas now after this break